This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客节目。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客节目《2%》。在这个奇特的现代世界里，我将为你剖析心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。节目名称中的“2”请拼写为T-W-O。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。1979年，那对我来说是一个意义重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家过得怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不太安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，这份特定的检测报告是你伪造了两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《被爱困住》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《被爱困住》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的20岁心理学》，这是一个带大家探讨我们在20岁时遇到的重大生活巨变和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客节目。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. You know the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we dive into the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to talk about something a little bit different. I think normally on this show we love to take a specific topic and dive into all of the studies, dive into all of the, of course, science behind it. But we're going to step back for today's episode and just look at the lives that we are creating from a holistic point of view and the ways in which we can actually design a life that we truly love based on, of course, like some of those core propositions and core theories to do with what makes us happy, what
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你们身处世界何地。你们都懂的。非常高兴大家能回来收听新的一期节目，让我们一同深入探讨20岁的心理学。今天，我们要聊点不太一样的话题。我想平时在这个节目里，我们很喜欢挑一个具体的主题，然后深入研究所有的研究成果，当然还有背后的所有科学依据。但在今天的节目中，我们要退一步，从整体的角度来看看我们正在创造的生活，以及如何根据那些核心命题和核心理论——当然，比如那些关于什么让我们快乐、什么让我们满足、以及从心理学的角度享受生活究竟意味着什么的理论——真正设计出一种我们真心热爱的生活。
makes us satisfied, what it actually means to enjoy life from a psychological perspective. I think a big worry for a lot of us in our 20s and me included is this kind of lingering question of how do I get the most out of my life? How do I ensure that when the time comes and I'm on my deathbed, there's nothing. left to do, there's nothing left to say that I can look back and be like, well, you know, wow, I had a really great life. Not just that, I had a life that I really loved. I think that very existential questioning of feeling like we have to make a lot of decisions right now to set ourselves up for future happiness can keep us up at night. You know, we want to feel in control.
我认为我们很多处于20岁的人，包括我自己，都有一个很大的担忧，那就是这个挥之不去的问题：我该如何最大限度地过好我的一生？我该如何确保当那一刻来临、我躺在临终病榻上时，没有什么是未了的心愿，没有什么是遗憾的话语，能够让我回首往事时说：“嗯，你知道的，哇，我这一生过得真的很棒。”不仅如此，我过着一种我真正热爱的生活。我认为，这种强烈的存在主义质问——感觉我们现在必须做出很多决定，来为未来的幸福奠定基础——会让我们在夜里辗转难眠。你知道的，我们渴望获得掌控感，
we want to feel like we have some say in choosing what we want from these, you know, 70 to 80 odd years that we get if we're lucky. And I think more than that general just sense of purpose and general sense of satisfaction, we also want that daily enjoyment. We want to wake up and be excited by the lives that we are creating, but also the lives that we are currently living. I think it's one of the best feelings in the world. when you go to sleep at night and just feel grateful. You feel grateful for your friends. You feel grateful
我们希望感觉自己在选择我们想要的这几十年（如果我们幸运的话，大约70到80年）的生活时拥有一些话语权。我认为，除了那种对目标感和满足感的普遍渴望之外，我们还渴望日常的快乐。我们希望醒来时对我们正在创造的生活、以及我们当前的生活感到兴奋。我认为这是世上最美妙的感觉之一，当你夜里入睡时，心中充满感激。你为你的朋友们感到感激，你为
for where you're at in your career. You feel grateful for all the joy and the happiness that you're experiencing and bringing. So how do we make that a reality? I think it's, you know, one of those big conundrums where at some stage you're going to reach a turning point and realize that what you've been doing so far might not actually create a future that you're really excited about, especially during this decade when we feel like we are on the cusp of a lot of huge life decisions, but also kind of at a crossroads where we're trying to make the best choice for us that's going to set us up for long-term happiness. I want to take some of the pressure off. I want to take some of the pressure off from feeling like there is a singular decision that is going to make you
你在职业生涯中取得的成就感到感激，你为所经历和带来的一切喜悦与幸福感到感激。那么，我们该如何将这一切变成现实呢？我认为，这是一个重大的难题，在某个阶段，你会到达一个转折点，并意识到你目前为止所做的事情，可能并不能真正为你创造一个让你感到无比兴奋的未来，尤其是在这个十年里，我们既觉得我们正处于许多重大生活决定的风口浪尖，同时也处于一个十字路口，试图为自己做出最好的选择，为长期的幸福打下基础。我想减轻一些压力。我想减轻那种认为存在着某个单一决定就能让你
happy in the future, a singular decision that is going to allow you to build a life that you love, and focus on those core principles and five kind of practical things that you can do that regardless, regardless of what's going on around you, regardless of what the world throws at you, regardless of your choices, you can still be happy. You can still feel contentment. And I don't think it's going to be necessarily easy. I'm not going to sit here and be like, oh, you know, just follow these five simple steps. You'll be done in 30 minutes.
未来感到幸福的压力，减轻那种认为存在着某个单一决定能让你建立起热爱的生活的压力，转而专注于那些核心原则以及你可以付诸实践的五个实用方法：无论周围发生什么，无论世界向你抛出什么挑战，无论你做出什么选择，你依然可以快乐。你依然可以感到满足。而且我认为这未必会是一件轻松的事。我不会坐在这里说：“哦，你知道的，只要遵循这五个简单的步骤，你就能在30分钟内搞定。”
It's like obviously not. Anything worth having, I think, comes with hard work. It comes with self-reflection. It comes with dedication. But the person that you are investing in is yourself. That's what I really want to remind you. Like, this is your best investment. Best investment ever is to set yourself up for a beautiful life.
显然不可能。任何值得拥有的东西，我都认为伴随着辛勤的付出。它伴随着自我反思。它伴随着奉献。但你所投资的对象正是你自己。这正是我真正想提醒你的。听着，这是你最好的投资。史上最好的投资就是为自己打造美好的人生。
To set yourself up for a life that you love. So let's talk through it today. I'm super excited for this episode. And I think if you're listening, hopefully you're excited as well. well. When we begin this process of essentially designing our lives and designing our futures, we cannot go into this transformation from a place of blindness. You know, we actually need to identify those crucial points where we are dissatisfied, where we are perhaps getting ourselves
为自己打造一种你所热爱的生活。所以今天我们来聊聊这个。我为这期节目感到超级兴奋。我想如果你在收听，希望你也会感到兴奋。当我们开始这个基本上是在设计我们的生活和未来的过程时，我们绝不能盲目地投入到这种转变中去。你知道的，我们实际上需要找出那些让我们感到不满的关键点，那些我们可能正让自己陷入
into a rut. Like what is actually the problem here that is causing us to want to take action? I think we tend to get stuck in the life that is easiest for us, the life that is convenient and comfortable, even though it's maybe not what we truly want. I think this is because as humans, we naturally crave our creature comforts and what is, you know, what seems familiar. We are innately scared of situations, events, choices that are going to disrupt the norm. It also might be that we don't necessarily feel. We are not necessarily feel like we have the tools that are necessary to redesign our life because we have become so stagnant and stuck in our patterns and stuck in our daily routine. We've kind of reached this point where we've
刻板僵局的地方。到底是什么问题导致我们想要采取行动？我想我们往往会困在对我们而言最轻松的生活中，那种方便且舒适的生活，尽管它可能并不是我们真正想要的。我想这是因为作为人类，我们天生渴望物质上的舒适以及我们所熟悉的事物。我们打心底里害怕那些会打破常规的情境、事件和选择。这也可能是因为我们不觉得。我们不一定觉得自己拥有重新设计生活所需的工具，因为我们已经在原有的模式和日常中变得过于停滞不前和固步自封。我们已经到了这样一种地步：我们
stopped believing in our agency and in our self-efficacy, which is essentially our sense of feeling in control of our decisions and our future. That is a really hard pattern to break out of. And before we can build a life we love, I think we actually have to deconstruct the one that we have. And even if you are at like a seven or an eight or even a nine out of ten on like life satisfaction, it's still possible to really raise that ceiling for what you want and what you expect. So this first tip, this entire approach of deconstructing the life you have really relies on choosing courage over comfort and challenging what you have come to expect from life by identifying where maybe certain events and experiences are not contributing to your expectations
不再相信自己的能动性和自我效能感，而这本质上就是我们对掌控自己的决策和未来的感觉。要打破这种模式真的很难。而在我们建立热爱的生活之前，我认为我们实际上必须先解构现有的生活。而且，即使你在生活满意度上能打七分、八分甚至十分里的九分，你依然可以真正拉高你对自己想要和期待的事物的上限。因此，第一个建议，即解构你现有生活的整个方法，确实依赖于选择勇气而非舒适，并通过找出某些事件和体验可能没有达到你的预期、从而挑战你对生活的既定期待，进而围绕这种潜力——改进的潜力——来塑造你的生活。
and shaping your life around that potential, that potential for improvement. So what we need to look at in general is kind of the four biggest areas of life where we feel the most to satisfaction. We have money and career, of course. We have our relationships. We have our health, which includes mental health. And then this final one, which I think we don't often discuss. which is values and spirituality.
所以我们需要总体审视的是生活中感到最不满足的四个最大领域。当然，首先是金钱和事业。其次是人际关系。然后是健康，其中包括心理健康。最后这个领域，我认为我们往往讨论得不多，那就是价值观和灵性。
And I'm including that last one because I think it is a facet of our mental and psychological well-being that we often neglect. It's very hard, though, to feel like you are building this life that you love when you don't actually believe in anything, when you have nothing to put your faith in. And that doesn't necessarily have to do with religion. I think values are equally as important. But more than that, a sense that you have a mission and a purpose in life. That could be a mission to improve the lives of others, a mission to create something beautiful,
我把最后这个加进来，是因为我认为它是我们常常忽视的精神和心理健康的一个方面。说实话，当你对任何事情都不坚信、当你的信仰无处安放时，要想觉得自己正在建立这种热爱的生活是极其困难的。这倒不一定非得跟宗教有关。我认为价值观同样重要。但更重要的是，你要有一种生活使命感和目标感。那可能是一个改善他人生活的使命，一个创造美丽事物的使命，
to solve some problem that we see. I think we all need something that we're passionate about and something that drives us. It is very hard to even feel like you want to change your life if there's no direction for that. You know, the other areas are pretty self-explanatory. I think we all know what it means to be dissatisfied in a job or in a relationship or dissatisfied with our health. You know, who doesn't worry about those things at least once a week or even daily, you know, because they are truly a foundation for a happy life.
去解决我们所看到的某个问题的使命。我认为我们都需要一些让我们充满激情、有所驱动的东西。如果没有方向感，你甚至很难产生想要改变生活的想法。你知道的，其他几个领域都比较不言自明。我想我们都知道对工作或人际关系不满意、或者对健康不满意意味着什么。你知道的，谁不会每周至少一次甚至每天都为这些事情担忧呢，因为它们确实是幸福生活的基石。
The easiest way, though, to identify what your main source of dissatisfaction is, is to actually follow the stress, to notice where you carry the most stress. what do you think about the most when your thoughts are wondering or when you're falling asleep and all the busyness of the day has kind of ceased? What are you left thinking about in those moments? Is it, you know, I wish I didn't have to go to work tomorrow. I wish that I was doing something I was genuinely excited to do. I wish I had more friends. I wish I felt more like myself in my own skin. How anxiety and worries might seem really scary. and really frustrating, and we might choose to avoid them because of the discomfort that they bring.
不过，要找出你不满的根源，最简单的方法其实就是顺藤摸瓜，去关注你压力最大的地方。当你思绪飘忽、或者当你在入睡前、白天的忙碌终于告一段落时，你脑子里想得最多的是什么？在那些时刻，你满脑子都在想些什么？是不是“我真希望明天不用去上班”？“我真希望我正在做一件我打心底里兴奋的事”。“我真希望我能有更多的朋友”。“我真希望我在自己的皮囊里能更像我自己”。焦虑和担忧看起来或许很吓人，
However, I think that is the biggest mistake we make. And that the reason why is because these worries, these fears, firstly, when we ignore them, we know that suppression inevitably will lead to these fears just gaining more power over us because we are avoiding them. But when it comes to building a life we love, those worries are your best friend because they are shining a bright neon flashing light exactly where you should be starting, where there is the most room for improvement. So maybe you're at this point where I'm going to use that example of like you're super
而且非常烦人，由于它们带来的不适感，我们可能会选择逃避。然而，我认为这是我们犯下的最大错误。其原因在于，这些担忧和恐惧——首先，当我们忽视它们时，我们知道压抑不可避免地会导致这些恐惧对我们产生更大的控制力，因为我们在逃避它们。但当谈到建立热爱的生活时，这些担忧却是你最好的朋友，因为它们像一盏耀眼的霓虹闪烁灯，准确地照亮了你应该开始的地方，那里也是最需要改进的地方。所以也许你正处于我刚才举的那个例子那种状态，比如你对
dissatisfied with your career. That's a really big one for a lot of us. It's not fulfilling. You're bored. You're annoyed at your co-workers. Sometimes the reason why we continue to stay in those situations in a life we don't love is because we don't know what it means to pursue a different kind of future. And we are scared of what that future might look like, that it might be worse.
自己的职业超级不满意。对于我们很多人来说，这是一个非常严重的问题。它毫无成就感。你感到无聊。你对同事感到恼火。有时，我们之所以继续留在那些我们并不热爱的生活中，是因为我们不知道追求一种不同未来意味着什么。而且我们害怕那种未来可能会是什么样，害怕它可能会变得更糟。
If the life you have found yourself in is not the life that you love, you really have a duty to question not only what needs to change and in what area, but what the potential outcome of a change might be. So I'm going to explain this a little bit further. there is an incredible book actually on this topic and it is literally called Designing Your Life. It's written by two Stanford professors. There's also a TED talk about it that I really recommend. And they talk about this exercise called the Odyssey Plan. So the time between like our 20s and our 30s is what they call our Odyssey years, like our years of exploration, where we are in this strange vacuum between childhood and what we see is real.
如果你发现自己身处的生活并不是你热爱的生活，你确实有责任去质疑不仅什么需要改变、在哪个领域改变，还要质疑改变的潜在结果可能是什么。所以我再进一步解释一下。其实有一本关于这个主题的极其精彩的书，书名就叫《设计你的人生》（Designing Your Life）。它是由斯坦福大学的两位教授写的。还有一个相关的TED演讲我也非常推荐。他们在书中谈到了一个叫做“奥德赛计划”（Odyssey Plan）的练习。所以，在我们的20岁到30岁之间这段时间，被他们称为我们的奥德赛岁月，就像我们的探索岁月，我们处于童年和我们所看到的真实成人世界之间的一个奇怪的真空期。
adulthood. And during this time, it is absolutely necessary to test in your mind different life paths or ideas about your future. A lot of the time, though, the way we are told to approach this is super limiting. You know, we're always told to think about our five-year plan or what do you want to be when you grow up or what are you going to do next? What are you going to do after graduation? After high school, after this job contract ends. That way of approaching the future doesn't actually allow us to be creative because it suggests that there is one answer. But the idea behind this Odyssey plan exercise is to think a bit broader and to come up with three different plans or versions of your future life by asking yourself three questions. If your life was to continue the way it was,
在这个时期，在脑海中测试不同的生活路径或对未来的构想是绝对必要的。然而，很多时候，我们被告知要采取的方法是非常局限的。你知道的，我们总是被告知要去思考我们的五年计划，或者你长大后想做什么，或者你接下来要做什么？毕业后要做什么？高中毕业后，在这份工作合同结束后要做什么。这种看待未来的方式实际上并不允许我们发挥创造力，因为它暗示只有一个答案。但这个奥德赛计划练习背后的理念是，通过问自己三个问题，把眼光放得更宽广一些，为你未来的生活想出三个不同的计划或版本。如果你的生活照常继续下去，
what would a day in five years time look like? Go into as much detail as possible. We've talked about this before, but what are you eating for breakfast? Who are you living with? Where are you living? What does your day look like? What do you do for fun? Imagine that situation, five years from now, nothing changes. Now think about what happens if this plan that you're currently living out doesn't work. What would you want from your life instead? And what would a day in your life in five years time look like then? If this plan A, of this current routine doesn't work out? What would you choose instead? Would it be any different? Are you maybe picturing yourself happier or more fulfilled? And finally, what would a day in your life look like in five years time if money, time and social expectations did not matter if you could do exactly what you wanted?
五年后的某一天会是什么样子？尽可能详细地描述。我们以前讨论过这个，但你早餐在吃什么？你和谁住在一起？你住在哪里？你的一天是什么样子的？你平时做什么消遣？想象一下这种情景，从现在起五年后，一切都没有改变。现在想想，如果你目前正在执行的这个计划行不通会发生什么？你希望你的生活变成什么样？那么，五年后你生活中的一天又会是什么样子？如果这个A计划——即当前的日常生活——行不通呢？你会选择什么来代替它？会有所不同吗？你或许会想象自己变得更快乐、更充实吗？最后，如果金钱、时间和社会期望都无关紧要，如果你能完全随心所欲，五年后你生活中的一天会是什么样子？
How do you feel then? So I think the last question always gets people in a bit of a tizzy because they're like, well, you know, money and time and social expectations do matter. Of course they do. Of course they matter. They are so limiting, very limiting. And it's not to say that you need to picture this like ideal life and live it out. It's more so being like if you take away all of these external factors that control our happiness, what is the core of your idea of a happy life when none of these things matter. And it's really interesting to see how this exercise changes the older you get. So for example, when I first did this exercise a few years back, I was 20. And I was, oh my gosh, I think I was still working in hospitality. I must have been. I was still working in hospitality. And you know what?
那时候你的感受如何？所以我觉得最后一个问题总是让大家有点手足无措，因为他们会觉得，“嗯，你知道的，金钱、时间和社会期望确实很重要啊。”它们当然重要。它们当然很重要。它们极具限制性，非常具有局限性。这倒不是说你需要去想象这种理想的生活并把它过出来。更多的是在假设，如果你剥夺了所有这些控制我们幸福的外部因素，当所有这些都不重要时，你对幸福生活的核心概念是什么。而且很有趣的是，随着年龄的增长，这个练习会如何发生变化。比如，几年前我第一次做这个练习时，我20岁。
If I was still working in hospitality now, I think I would be miserable. My year, you know, day in a life five years from back then would not be a life that I necessarily want now. My backup plan was I'm going to go into consulting, which I did actually end up doing. And you know what? That life was really amazing for some time. But when I really thought about it, and I started contemplating that final idea of a life where you are not constrained by money time, social expectations, I got a better idea of what I really wanted to do. And that was to do something where I was creative, where I was my own boss, and where I lived according to that mission that we were talking about before. So this multiverse exercise, I think the real power and significance in it is that
当时，天哪，我想我还在餐饮业工作。我肯定是的。我当时还在餐饮业工作。你知道吗？如果我现在还在餐饮业工作，我想我会痛苦不堪。从那时算起的五年后，我生活中的一天绝对不会是我现在想要的生活。我的备用计划是去咨询行业，而我实际上也确实这么做了。你知道吗？那段生活在一段时间里确实非常精彩。但当我真正深入思考它，并开始琢磨那个终极设想——即不受金钱、时间和社会期望束缚的生活——时，我对自己真正想做什么有了更好的想法。那就是去做一些具有创造性、能让我成为自己的老板、并且符合我们之前谈到的那个使命的事情。所以这个多元宇宙练习，我认为其真正的力量和意义在于，
it allows you to recognize what life has to offer. And it allows you to not be scared when things don't go according to plan and embrace the courage of change and practical change, things that you are going to change. So after deconstructing your life and identifying where you aren't dissatisfied and how that might need to change in the next five years, what it could look like, you need to start prototyping and testing those different versions of the future. To start with, choose one area that you can improve where you will see the most growth. So for example, we've talked about the career one quite a bit, but health is another really big element of this. And often it is a huge source of dissatisfaction for us. We don't like how we feel in our bodies. We don't like how we're treating
它能让你认清生活所能提供的一切。它能让你在事情不按计划进行时不再感到害怕，并拥抱改变的勇气和切实可行的改变——那些你将要做出的改变。因此，在解构了你的生活、找出了你不满意的地方以及未来五年可能需要如何改变、它会是什么样子之后，你需要开始制作原型并测试未来那些不同的版本。首先，选择一个你可以改善且能看到最大成长的领域。比如，我们已经讨论过不少关于职业的话题，但健康则是另一个非常重要的要素。而且它往往是我们极其不满意的源头。我们不喜欢身体给我们的感觉。我们不喜欢我们对待自己的方式。
ourselves. We don't like X, Y, and Z. That is holding you back from a happy life and is your duty to change it. So instead of going in and being like, all or nothing, I'm going to become like the fittest version of myself. I'm going to be so healthy. I'm never going to have a depressed or anxious thought ever. instead what you want to do is spend just 15 minutes a day working on that area of your life in a positive direction whether it is exercising for 15 minutes building your resume for 15 minutes or finding a passion project that you do every day 15 minutes that contributes to future career opportunities 15 minutes of texting back all your friends or giving them a call building that community that little change is going to go a long way.
我们不喜欢这样、那样和这般。这阻碍了你过上幸福的生活，你理应去改变它。所以，不要采取“全盘皆输”或者“要么全盘接受，要么一刀切”的态度，比如“我要成为最健康的自己。我要变得超级健康。我再也不会有任何沮丧或焦虑的想法了。”相反，你想要做的是每天花短短15分钟在积极的方向上改善你生活的那个领域，无论是锻炼15分钟、花15分钟完善简历，还是寻找一个你每天都去做的爱好项目、每天花15分钟为未来的职业机会添砖加瓦、花15分钟回复所有朋友的信息或给他们打个电话、建立那个社交圈，这种小小的改变将会产生深远的影响。
I think the reason why is twofold. Firstly, when we think about like creating our dream life, often we do think about this big future, right? That's like 20 years down the line. And that is so daunting. And when we just think about the outcome, it is so big in our minds and we want to get there so fast with such impatient creatures that we forget
我想原因有两点。首先，当我们考虑创造理想中的生活时，我们通常会去构想那个宏大的未来，对吧？那是20年后的事。这太令人畏惧了。当我们只想着最终结果时，它在我们脑海中显得如此宏大，以至于我们如此急切地想要以极快的速度达到那个目标，而我们这些极其缺乏耐心的人却忘记了
that we actually have to be acting on our dreams and goals. Your dream life might involve a really nice terrorist in a big city. Sadly, that's not going to happen overnight, but it will happen if you take 15 minutes a day to educate yourself on investing or to go over your spending. If you want to one day write a book that you get a hold in your hands and say, you know, I wrote this book. I wrote every word. That doesn't happen from wishful thinking. It happens from writing for just 15 minutes every day. And the 15 minute rule really helps us overcome our all or nothing thinking that keeps us in a place where we are scared of even starting. I think this fear of starting comes from a few things. The biggest one to me is perfectionism.
我们实际上必须对自己的梦想和目标付诸行动。你理想中的生活可能包括大城市里一个非常漂亮的露台。遗憾的是，这不会在一夜之间发生，但如果你每天花15分钟学习投资理财知识，或者梳理一下自己的开销，它就会发生。如果你有一天想写一本书，能拿在手里说：“看，我写了这本书。每个字都是我写的。”这绝不是靠痴心妄想就能实现的。它靠的是每天坚持写作15分钟。15分钟法则真的能帮我们克服“非黑即白”的思维模式，这种思维模式往往把我们困在连开始都感到害怕的境地。我认为这种害怕开始的心态源于几件事。对我而言，最主要的一点就是完美主义。
I talk about this quite a bit, this idea of perfectionism procrastination. If we aren't completely sure that our plan is going to work, that our future is going to be perfect, why start, why even begin? Because we are so held back by this sense that if it's not exactly what I want, why should I put in the effort? Why should I face the possibility of failing, the possibility of setting my sights really high and not be able to reach them and being disappointed? So that's one of the first reasons is when we want to create our dream life, when we want to change something really significant, it's very daunting because there is a lot of room for failure. And the other thing is to do with analysis paralysis. Something that I really like to talk about is choice overload. This idea that
我经常谈到这一点，也就是完美主义拖延症。如果我们不能完全确信我们的计划会成功、我们的未来会完美，那为什么还要开始，为什么甚至要迈出第一步呢？因为我们被这样一种观念深深束缚着：如果它不是我想要的百分之百完美，我为什么要付出努力？我为什么要面对可能失败的可能性，面对把目标定得极高却无法达成、最终感到失望的可能性？所以这是最初的原因之一：当我们想要创造理想生活、想要改变一些非常重大的事情时，这让人望而生畏，因为里面有太多的失败空间。另一个原因则与分析瘫痪（analysis paralysis）有关。我真的很喜欢谈论的一个概念是“选择过载”（choice overload）。这种想法认为，
there is a lot of different choices for people like you and I in our 20s. And often we think that having a lot of choice brings about a lot of freedom, brings about a lot of options. It actually does the opposite. It creates this thing called analysis paralysis where because there are so many paths that we can take into our future lives because there are so many different things that we want to do. We want to travel. We want the career. We want to settle down. We want to go and pursue acting or whatever it is because there are so many different dreams that we hold at one time. It is so hard to choose one so we don't choose any of them at all. That means that not only do we not create, we just don't end up creating any life that we love because it's so much easier, like I said, to just
像你我这样处于20多岁的人，面临着许许多多不同的选择。我们常常以为拥有很多选择会带来很多自由、带来很多选项。但实际上它起到了相反的作用。它会产生一种叫做“分析瘫痪”的现象：由于我们可以通往未来生活的路径有那么多，因为我们想要做的事情有那么多。我们想去旅行。我们想要事业。我们想安定下来。我们想去追求演艺事业或诸如此类的东西——正因为我们同时怀揣着如此之多的不同梦想，所以要挑选其中一个实在是太难了，以至于我们索性一个也不选了。这意味着，我们不仅没有去创造，我们最终甚至没有创造出任何我们热爱的生活，因为正如我所说，留在那个让我们感到舒适、不必挑战自我的地方要容易得多。我们不必去经历那些潜在的在精神和情感上让人感到不适的体验，比如失败。但我认为15分钟法则能让我们逐渐习惯风险，习惯我们需要的一些纪律，并慢慢看到改善，以至于当需要做出重大改变的时刻来临之时，我们已经做好了准备。我妈妈以前总爱说这样一句话：
stay in the place where we're comfortable, we don't have to challenge ourselves. We don't have to potentially go through mentally and emotionally uncomfortable experiences such as failure. But I think the 15-minute rule allows us to get comfortable with the risk and get comfortable with some of the discipline that we need and slowly see improvements such that when the time comes that we might have to make a big change, we already feel prepared. And my mom used to always have this saying, Shout out to my mom. She's amazing. Very wise woman. And you know what? It probably isn't even her saying, but I'm going to give her credit for it. But she used to always say, the easiest things aren't always worth having because if everyone could have it, they would. And when you think about 15 minutes,
向我妈致敬。她太棒了。一位非常睿智的女性。你知道吗？这可能甚至都不是她自己说的，但我还是要把它记在她头上。但她以前总是说：“最容易得到的东西往往不值得拥有，因为如果所有人都能得到，那它就毫无价值了。”当你想到15分钟时，
15 minutes to devote to just something that you really want in your life that's really going to improve your life, the majority of people don't take that time at all. You also discovered that with each of these days that you continue to do something that you love and do something that's good for you, what you're actually going to find is what you really want in life. So I'm going to explain that a little bit. When we set our sites and we say, okay, I want to do this thing for 15 minutes. Say, for example, that's writing. When we begin to notice that that 15 minutes starts turning into an hour or even more, you realize that you're doing it because it's something that you love and it's become part of your lifestyle.
抽出15分钟全身心投入到某件你真心渴望、真正能改善你生活的事情上，大多数人根本连这点时间都不愿意花。你还会发现，随着你日复一日地坚持做你热爱且有益于你的事情，你真正会发现的是你在生活中真正想要的是什么。所以我来稍微解释一下。当我们设定目标并说：“好吧，我想花15分钟做这件事。”比方说，那是写作。当我们开始注意到那15分钟开始变成一个小时甚至更久时，你就会意识到你之所以在做它，是因为这是你热爱的事，并且它已经成为了你生活方式的一部分。
Creating the life you love is not about huge, massive decisions that are going to completely move you to a whole new spectrum of life and they're not going to completely change your path in the moment. It's also about building up good habits towards the practices and the future that you want to build over time. So we've spoken a lot about the planning phase and what we can contribute to our lives. through those small moments. And, you know, that is really amazing to have vision.
创造你热爱的生活，并不在于那些能瞬间将你带入全新生活轨道的重大决定，它们也不会在当下彻底改变你的道路。它同样关乎随着时间的推移，朝着你想要建立的实践和未来培养出良好的习惯。所以我们已经聊了很多关于规划阶段的内容，以及我们可以通过那些微小的时刻为生活做出怎样的贡献。而且，你知道的，拥有愿景确实非常了不起。
But we equally need to identify the things that don't make us happy. I think improving your life isn't always about addition. Sometimes it's about subtraction as well. And I think that's something that the self-help space sometimes misses. You know, it's always a new lifestyle plan or a new trending exercise or a book or a product or more relationships or more healthy food. or more whatever. But sometimes we actually need to be in the space and the mindset of removal. We kind of need to, you know, murray, condo our lives and the habits that are holding us back.
但我们同样需要找出那些让我们不快乐的事情。我认为改善生活并不总是靠“做加法”。有时它也关乎“做减法”。我认为这是个人成长领域有时会忽略的一点。你知道的，它总是一个新的生活方式计划、或者一套新的流行锻炼方法、一本书、一款产品、更多的社交关系、更健康的食物，
It's hard to fully love the life that you are creating when you are beholden to a nasty friendship. Or you are eating food that makes you feel unwell all the time. Or you have a routine that leaves you bored and miserable and unable to wake up in the morning or a job that is completely draining you. there is nothing that you can continue to add to your life that is ever going to replace the things that continue to drain your energy. And there's a quote I saw the other day that I think really puts this quite well, which is your new life is going to cost you your old one. And that includes those habits that hold us back, that we might, you know, might make us happy in the moment or which are too difficult to address, but in the long term, end up,
或是更多诸如此类的东西。但有时我们真正需要的，是一种剔除的心态和思维模式。我们有点需要对生活和那些拖累我们的习惯进行一番“近藤麻理惠式的断舍离”。当你受制于一段糟糕的友谊时，你很难完全热爱你正在创造的生活。或者你一直在吃那些让你身体感到不舒服的食物。或者你过着一种让你感到无聊、痛苦且早上无法醒来的日常生活，或者是一份彻底榨干你精力的工作。
acting as almost a form of self-sabotage. I have an example of this for you. It's around drinking. And if you listen to an episode I did a while back around should you quit drinking in your 20s, you'll know a bit about this story. But for the longest time, I had a really bad relationship with alcohol. I think that I grew up really wanting to be cool and really wanting to fit in and also being kind of socially anxious. and alcohol when I entered uni and even like post-grad life, alcohol is like the most amazing social lubricant
生活中没有任何东西是你不断往里添加、却能永远取代那些不断榨干你精力的事物的。我前几天看到过一句名言，我觉得它把这一点阐述得相当好，那就是：“你的新生活将让你付出旧生活的代价。”这其中就包括那些拖累我们的习惯——它们可能在当下让我们感到快乐，或是太难以处理，但从长远来看，
and it makes everything feel more fun and more free and it's just such an easy way to socialize with people. I began to realize though that actually alcohol was one of the biggest things that was almost acting to undermine the life that I wanted.
最终几乎起到了一种自我破坏的形式。我有一个关于这方面的例子。是关于喝酒的。如果你听过我前段时间做的一期关于“你是否应该在20岁时戒酒”的节目，你就会对这个故事略知一二。但在很长一段时间里，我和酒精的关系非常糟糕。我觉得我成长过程中非常渴望变得很酷、非常渴望融入集体，同时又有点社交焦虑。
Every time I would drink, I would always, I didn't really know when to stop, if that makes sense. I didn't really know what it was like to not drink every day. And I would always kind of find a way to kind of do that. And what ended up happening was I was always completely, you know, physically drained. I didn't feel healthy. I didn't always have a hangover. But when I did, it really like wasn't great. I couldn't be productive. And I think that that's a great example of almost like addition by subtraction, your life improving by removing things that you might feel completely reliant on, but which are actually causing you a lot of
而当我进入大学甚至是研究生生活后，酒精就像是最神奇的社交润滑剂，它让一切都感觉更有趣、更自由，而且这确实是与人社交的一种极其简便的方式。然而我开始意识到，实际上酒精恰恰是几乎在暗中破坏我想要的生活的最大元凶之一。
long-term suffering. And it's about identifying what's a driving you to keep those things in your life, even when they're at the expense of your future self. Is it peer pressure? Is it loneliness? Is it dependence? Those things all take away our ability to control our life. lives and kind of be the director, you know, like we want to be the writer, the producer, the director of our lives. We want to be in control, not our impulses, not our cravings, not our fixations, not our bad relationships. So I think cutting things out obviously takes a lot of focus. And the thing that a lot of us make, I think the biggest mistake a lot of us make is that we just want to try and transform every domain of our life at once. And we want to just,
每次我喝酒，我总是——如果这么说能说得通的话——我真的不知道什么时候该停下来。我真的不知道每天不喝酒会是什么样子。我总是会想方设法去喝上一杯。结果就是我总是彻底地（你知道的）体力透支。我感觉自己很不健康。虽然我并非每次宿醉，但每当宿醉的时候，那感觉真的很糟糕。我无法保持高效。而我认为，这就是“减法带来加法”的一个绝佳例子：通过剔除那些你可能觉得完全依赖、但实际上正在给你带来许多长期痛苦的事物，你的生活得到了改善。这关乎去找出是什么在驱动你把这些东西留在你的生活中，即使它们是以牺牲未来的自我为代价。是同辈压力吗？是孤独感吗？是依赖性吗？所有这些东西都剥夺了我们掌控自己生活的能力，剥夺了我们去成为导演的能力——你知道的，就像我们想成为自己生活中的编剧、制片人和导演一样。我们希望掌握控制权，而不是让我们的冲动、食欲、执念或糟糕的人际关系来掌控。所以我觉得砍掉一些东西显然需要全神贯注。而我们很多人犯的错误——我认为我们很多人犯的最大错误——就是我们只想试着一下子改造生活中的每一个领域，
just do a whole big cleanse. Instead, I want you to think about the one thing that is holding you back right now, only one, and focus on that. Put your energy into removing that from your life. I always like to imagine the kind of final hero story, if that makes sense, what it will feel like to tell someone in six months, in a year, in five years, what that journey was like for me. Like, wow, that was a really hard decision,
并且只想来一次彻底的大清洗。相反，我希望你去思考当下正在拖累你的那一件事情——只需一件——然后专注于它。把你的精力投入到把它从你的生活中剔除出去。我总是喜欢想象那种最终的英雄故事，如果这么说能说得通的话：在六个月、一年、五年后，向别人讲述这段对我来说是怎样的旅程，会是一种什么感觉。就像：“哇，那真是一个艰难的决定，
but I'm glad that I did it. I can tell you that I did this from the point of hindsight, being in a space where that thing is no longer in my life. You know, I'm so glad that I quit vaping when I was 25 and not at 40. I'm so glad I decided to stop drinking every night. I'm so glad that I realized at 23
但我很高兴我这么做了。”我可以告诉你，我是站在事后诸葛亮的角度来看待这一点的，正身处那个东西已经不再存在于我生活中的空间里。你知道的，我太庆幸自己能在25岁而不是40岁时戒掉电子烟了。我太庆幸自己决定停止每晚喝酒了。我太庆幸自己能在23岁时就意识到那个人对我不适合，而不是等到30岁、白白浪费了七年时间再去采取行动。而一直以来，这些事情实际上都在阻碍我真正去过上属于我自己的、充满成就感的生活。所以我们现在要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想要聊聊更多令人愉悦的习惯和实践，我认为我们在设计一种不仅让我们热爱、而且让我们发自内心地彻底迷恋的生活时，所有人都需要运用这些。所以我们在这个简短的休息之后见！2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。
that that person was not good for me and not at 30 when I had seven years to act. And all along, these things were actually keeping me from being truly fulfilled by a life that is my own. So we're going to take a quick break now, but when we return, I want to talk about a few more kind of joyous habits and practices that I think we all need to apply when designing a life that we don't just love, but we absolutely and truly adore. So we'll be back after this short break? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将为你剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界里培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些充斥在健康产业中的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of,
压力导致的。经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《2%》。节目名称中的“2%”请读作TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备在白天聊聊快克，不过为了让大家知道——我是说，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆到台面上来了。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table. right now.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖姆斯。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的丰富经验，
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field. and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different.
我们根本不知道什么时候才算做够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
意图，兄弟。没错。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能发自内心地去做一个好人。我是凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），欢迎加入我的全新播客《The Hard Way》，我们将在这里就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这场持续多年的法庭之战由此拉开序幕，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young），这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻
at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I don't know who needs a reminder of this, but life is meant to be really, really fun.
亚利桑那州马里科帕县传来消息，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我不知道谁需要这样一个提醒，但生活本来就应该充满真正的、极大的乐趣。
And there are meant to be really amazing moments. And it's okay and totally amazing to be excited by things and to be pursuing happiness and pursuing joy and pursuing nostalgia and like ecstasy and like all the good and happy feelings. Sometimes I think we forget that in kind of the structures of daily living. and particularly in a world that really focuses on material possessions and material wealth. But if you've listened to this podcast for a while, you will know that joy is such an important emotion and such an important emotion for creating a life that you love is putting joy at the center of what you choose to do.
而且生活中本该有许多真正美妙的时刻。因事物而兴奋，去追求幸福、追求快乐、追求怀旧、追求狂喜以及所有美好快乐的感觉，这是完全可以的，也是再棒不过的事。有时我想，在日常生活结构中，我们忘记了这一点，特别是在一个真正专注于物质占有和物质财富的世界里。但如果你听这个播客一段时间，你就会知道快乐是如此重要的一种情绪，对于创造你热爱生活而言，把快乐放在你选择做的事情的核心，是如此重要的一种情绪。
We overlook this feeling in so many conversations and sometimes we overlook it for things like love and we overlook it for things like happiness. But joy is so much more delicate and beautiful and easy to kind of cure and easy to find. I think it's also something that is so immaterial and yet such a key ingredient to happiness and life satisfaction. I've actually been looking into this a lot recently and we're seeing so much evidence for the power of joy coming out of a bunch of really huge research institutions like Harvard and Stanford. All of them say, saying that more than money, more than fame, more than success, more than even good genes, joy is one of the most powerful factors in what determines a good life.
我们在太多的对话中忽视了这种感觉，有时我们为了爱而忽视它，有时我们为了幸福而忽视它。但快乐要微妙得多、美丽得多，也更容易治愈、更容易找到。我认为这也是一种完全无形却又是幸福和生活满意度的核心要素。事实上，我最近深入研究了这一点，我们从哈佛和斯坦福等许多大型研究机构那里看到了大量关于快乐力量的证据。他们所有人都说，比起金钱、比起名誉、比起成功、甚至比起优秀的基因，快乐是决定美好生活的最强大因素之一。
One of the longest longitudinal studies ever conducted in the history of modern psychology and modern medicine focused on what made a good life. They recruited 268 sophomores from Harvard back in the 1930s, and they followed them for 80 years. And then they also followed their children. And these days, only 19 of the original 268 are alive. But by tracking these individuals for essentially their whole lives, they were able to see exactly what determined longevity and happiness and health into those later decades.
现代心理学和现代医药学历史上进行过的历时最长的纵向研究之一，重点关注的是什么造就了美好生活。他们在 20 世纪 30 年代从哈佛招募了 268 名大二学生，并对他们进行了长达 80 年的追踪调查。后来他们还追踪了这些人的子女。如今，最初的 268 人中只有 19 人还在世。但通过对这些人进行几乎是一生的追踪，他们能够准确地看出是什么决定了他们在晚年数十年的长寿、幸福和健康。
And what they found was amazing. They showed how protective, healthy relationships are for our health, how important empathy is, and also optimism, and how things like joy and looking for good things in your life. life even when they're not there and hard to find keeps you mentally sharp, it keeps you curious, it keeps you excited. We are often really hard at work designing our dream life that it means that we sacrifice daily enjoyment. We get really focused on being productive and working hard and that negates a lot of the significant beauty that we'll find in small silent moments. So I want you to
他们发现的结果令人惊叹。他们展示了健康的关爱关系对我们的健康有多么具有保护作用，同理心以及乐观精神有多么重要，以及像快乐和在生活中寻找美好事物——即使它们并不存在且很难找到——如何能让你保持思维敏捷、充满好奇心、感到兴奋。我们常常非常辛苦地设计我们的梦想生活，以至于这意味着我们牺牲了日常的快乐。我们变得非常专注于提高生产力和努力工作，而这消解了我们在安静的小时刻中所能发现的许多重大美感。所以我希望你
create joy for yourself. And every day I want you to find three things that make you think, oh my God, it's really amazing that I get to be alive. That is just so beautiful and special and human and whatever it is. The example I love to give is this time that really sticks in my memory when I was coming home from back when I worked my 9 to 5 when I was a consultant. And it was really late at night. I was so exhausted. I'd been working so hard those few months. And there was this little girl on the train. And she had this big brown. leaf and she was just twirling it and patting it and petting it and I was like that is the most joyous beautiful thing is looking and it's like observing someone else's acknowledgement of like beauty
为自己创造快乐。我希望你每天都能找到三件让你觉得“天哪，我能活在这个世上真是太棒了”的事情。那是如此美丽、特别、充满人性，无论它是什么。我喜欢举的例子是这样一个时刻，它深深地印在我的记忆中：那是我结束了朝九晚五的顾问工作回家的路上。那是深夜。我筋疲力尽。那几个月我工作太努力了。地铁里有个小女孩。她手里拿着一片巨大的棕色树叶，就在那儿转动着、轻拍着、抚摸着它，当时我想，这就是最快乐、最美妙的事情，去注视着，就像是去观察别人对美的认可
and observing someone else's like curiosity and when I started looking for that joy more often my life did get better because in that joy is also opportunity right there's opportunity for adventure there's opportunity to just have a better outlook about the state of the world as that is right now. And especially when it seems hard to find, search for those joyful moments, search for those three things during every day that make you be like, okay, like this is truly a blessing. I'm really happy to be here. And I'm going to make the most out of this and I'm going to just actually enjoy my life because that's what I'm here to do. I think we're up to my my fourth tip now. Yeah, my fourth tip. And that is to take time to actually be an interesting person. And not just about
去观察别人身上那种好奇心。当我开始更经常地寻找那种快乐时，我的生活确实变好了，因为在那快乐之中也蕴含着机会，对吧？有冒险的机会，有对世界现状抱有更好看法的机会。特别是当快乐似乎很难寻找时，去寻找那些快乐的时刻，在每一天里寻找那三件能让你觉得“好吧，这真的是一种祝福，我真的很高兴能来到这里，我要充分利用这一切，我要真正享受我的生活，因为这就是我来这里的意义”的事情。我想我们现在已经说到我的第四个建议了。是的，我的第四个建议。那就是花时间真正成为一个有趣的人。这不仅关乎
being, it's not just about being interesting to other people, but being interesting to yourself. I think we all know the experience of talking to someone and feeling like our life is one dimensional in comparison to theirs. And I think especially in this generation, we spend a lot of time doing things that don't necessarily contribute to long-term happiness or really anything that good. The one that I always think about is like scrolling on our phones and just like spending hours and hours on TikTok or Instagram or I don't know, do people use Facebook? I don't use Facebook, but Facebook.
存在，不仅在于对其他人而言很有趣，更在于对自己而言有趣。我想我们都有过这样的经历：与某人交谈时，觉得与他们相比，我们的生活显得非常单薄。而且我认为特别是在我们这一代，我们花了很多时间做那些不一定能带来长远幸福或任何真正美好的事情。我总是想到的一个例子就是刷手机，在 TikTok 或 Instagram 上花上几个小时又几个小时，或者我不知道，人们还用 Facebook 吗？我不用 Facebook，但 Facebook。
There you go. Twitter. X. Whatever it is. Those kind of activities have begun to surpass a lot of the activities that previous generations were involved in, you know, reading and being outdoors. And I'm not, not to say that there is like some form of elitism there, but I do think that when you are getting lost in your phone constantly and getting pulled in by that dopamine,
你看。Twitter。X。无论是什么。这类活动已经开始超越前几代人参与的许多活动，你知道的，比如阅读和亲近大自然。我并不是说这里面有什么精英主义，但我确实认为，当你不断地迷失在手机中并被多巴胺所吸引时，
it is not going to last and it is not going to contribute to making you someone who is interested in the world or interesting. One way that I really put this into perspective for myself was thinking about if I could remember the last five Instagram posts or TikToks that I watched or the last five, or at least tell myself five things that I saw on one of those apps in the past 24 hours. And I could never remember a single one of them. I could not remember it. And I realized that every part of my brain that I wanted for myself, that I really wanted to keep active, that I wanted to be healthy, was getting absolutely consumed during those periods.
这是不会持久的，它也无助于让你成为一个对世界感兴趣或有趣的人。我为自己真正客观看待这一点的一个方法是，回想一下我是否能记起我看过的最后五个 Instagram 帖子或 TikTok，或者过去 24 小时内在其中一个应用上看到的最后五件事，或者至少能说出五件事。而我从来记不住哪怕一件。我记不住。我意识到，我想要为自己保留的、我真正想要保持活跃的、我希望健康的脑海中的每一部分，在那段时间里都被彻底吞噬了。
And there were no memories being made. there was nothing really going on behind my eyes. Sometimes that's great. You know, it's really good for like relaxing and decompressing and toning on our lizard brain. But is that really a sustainable and healthy source of dopamine? And in this kind of short amount of time that we have on earth, is that making us someone who is interested and interesting? I think that that's not necessarily a question that I can answer.
而且没有产生任何记忆，我脑海深处真的什么也没发生。有时这很棒。你知道的，这对于放松、减压以及激活我们的爬行动物脑真的很有用。但这真的是一个可持续且健康的快乐来源吗？在这个我们在世上的短暂时间里，这能让我们成为一个有趣且引人入胜的人吗？我认为这不一定是一个我能为你解答的问题。
for you? It's a question that you have to answer for yourself. Is the time that you spend online detracting from the brilliant memories and experiences you could be making offline? So I think the reason that this has a place in this whole episode around building a life that you love is that you kind of want to end things, end, be at the end of your life and have stories and have moments that you can look back on and say, like, I did this. things. I did that. Memories and moments that contribute to kind of like the fabric of a lovely, beautiful, spectacular, interesting life. Part of that involves really pursuing hobbies. And I know that people kind of throw out hobbies as like a, this is just kind of like all healing
这是你需要自己去解答的问题。你在线上花费的时间，是否正在损害你在离线时本可以创造的美好记忆和体验？所以我想，这件事之所以在这集关于构建你热爱的生活的节目中有一席之地，是因为你希望在生命的尽头，拥有可以回首并讲述的故事和时刻，可以说：我做过这些事情，我做过那些。这些记忆和时刻构成了可爱、美丽、壮观、有趣的生活的基调。其中的一部分涉及真正追求爱好。我知道人们有时会把爱好当作一种疗愈的万灵药抛出来，比如“去培养个爱好吧，做这个，做那个”。但真的，我由衷地相信，这个世界上最好、最快乐的人，都是那些除了自身之外，还有真正热爱的事情可做的人。他们有朝着变得更好而努力的目标，不是因为这会给他们带来什么物质上的好处，不是因为这会显得多么令人印象深刻或诸如此类，而是因为他们真正融入了那些热爱的事情，融入了那些不仅能带来健康生活，还能带来充满活力生活的行动中。我的最后一个建议，我知道我刚才说了五个，但我的最后一个建议是进行积极的未来规划。我希望每一个听到这里的人，都能拥有一个非常漫长而美丽的人生。
antidote of like, just get a hobby. Just do this. Just do that. But no, I seriously do believe that some of the best people and happiest people in this world are people who have something beyond themselves that they really enjoy doing. They have something that they are working towards being better at, not because it's going to really get them anything material, not because it's going to be impressive or anything like that, but just because they're really tapped into what it means to do the things that they love and do the things that contribute to not just a healthy life, but a vibrant one. My final tip, and I know I said five, but my final tip is to engage in positive future planning. I hope for everyone listening to this that you have a very long and beautiful life.
享受漫长而美丽人生的一部分，其实就是为自己创造充满期待的事物，为未来那个快乐的自己进行规划，思考他们需要什么才能快乐。因此，有一个叫做“多巴胺规划”的概念，即我们刻意地——不是剥夺自己的多巴胺，而是刻意让自己经历努力工作的困难时期，带着对最终会有惊人成果的认知去追求我们的梦想。这并不一定意味着你需要经历那种坐过山车般的生活：埋头苦干、拼命加班、过度劳累，然后才能去度假。它更多的是确保你在生活中花时间去规划
Part of enjoying that long and beautiful life is actually giving yourself things to look forward to and planning for a future happy version of yourself and what they need to be happy. So there's this idea called dopamine scheduling where we deliberately, not deprive ourselves of dopamine, but deliberately like put ourselves through hard periods where we're working. working hard, where we're pursuing our dreams with the knowledge that at the end of that, there will be some incredible outcome. It doesn't necessarily mean that you need to have that kind of roller coaster of, you know, head down, bum up, really hard overworking and then you can go on a holiday. It's more about making sure that you take time during your life to schedule
那些能够让你快乐的活动、记忆和时刻。你不必等到退休才去旅行。你不必富有才能拥有丰富的体验。享受一次体验并不需要有人陪同。我认为这正是创造美好生活归结到底的关键所在：我们常常在等待条件完美才采取行动。我们在等待某种成功的标志或某种能给予我们许可去做的事件。我们想要做的事情。关于这一点，我有一个非常悲伤的故事要讲给你听，是关于一个家庭
activities and memories and moments that are going to make you happy. you don't have to wait until you retire to travel. You don't have to be rich to have rich experiences. You don't need someone to go with you to enjoy an experience. I think that's the big thing that comes down to creating a good life is that so often we are waiting for the conditions to be perfect before we take action. We are waiting for some kind of marker of success or some kind of event that's going to give us permission to do. the things that we want to do. I have a really sad story for you about this, about a family
朋友的，他的祖父母结婚很长时间了。当时他们大约 65 岁和 67 岁。爷爷一直说：“你知道的，我明年就要退休了。我明年退休，然后我们要去进行一次盛大的邮轮旅行。我们要去做所有工作时没能去成的旅行。明年就是那个年份。明年就是那个年份。明年就是那个年份。等我再多赚点钱，让我们生活得更舒适一点。”结果，在他们还没来得及做这些事情之前，她就去世了。所以我想，不要等待。不要等待。那个故事一直深深地印在我的脑海里，你知道的，我并不是很了解这个人。我不能说，我相信她一定度过了美好的一生，但我觉得把它当作一个民间故事来看待很重要，并且我们要想到，确实有这样的人，他们用一生的时间去等待，只为了在最后的 10 到 15 年里把他们想做的一切都塞进去。我不认为这是正确的方式。我不认为这是正确的方式。我认为，在可以的时候、当你有能力的时候、尽可能多地给自己创造体验，这本身就蕴含着巨大的美好。它也更有助于对未来抱持乐观态度。如果我们回想一下我们之前讨论过的哈佛研究，那些拥有积极的过去体验的人，对未来积极的体验会有更多的期待。
friend of mine whose grandparents were married for quite a while. And they were around 65 and 67. And the grandfather kept saying, you know, I'm going to retire next year. I'm going to retire next year and we're going to go on this big cruise. We're going to do all the travel that we never got to do while we were working. Next year will be the year. Next year will be the year. year will be the year. Let me just get a little bit more money so that we're more comfortable. And she actually ended up passing away before they ever got to do any of those things. So I think, don't wait. Don't wait. That story has always stuck with me of, and you know, I didn't know this person quite well. I can't say, I'm sure she had a beautiful life, but I think just treating it as like
他们有一种感觉，即美好的事物仍在前方。未来会有美好的事物，我想去经历它们，我想对那种生活保持乐观，即使我的青春可能已经流逝，即使我的骨头开始酸痛，我的未来依然会有美好的事物，因为我正在为之规划。我在为之加油助威。所以我想，这就是我们今天的全部内容了。我构建热爱的生活的五个实用建议。
a bit of a folk story is important and thinking about the fact that there are people out there who really do wait their entire lives to cram in everything they wanted to do in the last 10, 15 years. And I don't think that that's the way to go. I don't think that that's the way to go. I think that there is so much beauty in giving yourself the experiences when you can whilst you can as much as you can. It also just contributes to more optimism about the future. And if we think back to that Harvard study we were talking about, people who have positive, positive past experiences, like kind of have more expectation about future positive experiences.
我要快速回顾并提醒你们它们是什么。首先，在我们构建热爱的生活之前，你必须解构你旧的生活。接下来是 15 分钟规则。开始原型设计并测试你未来的不同版本可能会是什么样子，并开始实施方法，将那个未来的自己带入你当前和现在的自我中。接下来，这不仅仅是做加法，也是做减法。移除你生活中那些不能给你带来快乐、你可以现实地将其剔除的事物。
They have the sense of like there are still good things coming. There are good things in the future and I want to be there for them and I want to stay optimistic for what that life will look like. Even when maybe my youth has passed, even when my bones ache, like there are still good things in my future because I am planning on them. I'm rooting on them. So I think that is all that we have for today. my five practical tips to build a life that you love.
第四点是追求日常的快乐，当然，还要花时间做一个有趣的人，对自己保持兴趣，最后，参与到积极的未来规划中去。我真心希望这期节目能带给你新的视角，给你一些启发。这也是我经常思考的一个问题，我最大的恐惧之一就是带着遗憾生活。我真的很担心自己到了某个年纪，却发现我一直想做的事情已经不再属于我了，我没有钱，没有时间，没有自由，没有体力去做了。这对我来说是一个非常可怕的想法。这是一个非常可怕的担忧，我可能会对我的生活感到遗憾，也许有朝一日
I'm going to quickly go back and remind you of what they are. Firstly, before we can build a life you love, you have to deconstruct your old life. Next is the 15 minutes rule. Start prototyping and testing what a different version of your future could look like and start implementing ways to bring that future you into your current and present self. Next, it's not all about addition. It's also about subtraction. the things in your life that are not bringing you happiness that you can realistically remove.
我会回过头来，意识到自己没有抓住需要的机会。然而，我认为这个视角允许这一切的存在，它允许这样一个事实的存在：生活中没有单一的事情能让你成为世界上最快乐的人，也没有单一的事情能带给你完全彻底的满足感。这是一种心态，是一种每天做事情的心态，这些事情让你走上通往快乐的道路，向你日复一日地证明，你正在投资那个未来的自己，你正致力于当前这个版本的自己，给他们最好的体验，给他们所能要求的一切快乐，同时也融入纪律，确保你敞开大门，
Number four is to pursue daily joy and, of course, take time to be an interesting person and to be interested in yourself and finally engage in that positive future planning. I really hope that this episode brought you in your perspective gave you something to think about. It's something that I think about a lot in the sense of one of my biggest fears is living with regret. And I really worry that I'll get to a certain age and realize that the things that I always wanted to do are no longer available to me, that I won't have the money, I won't have the time, I won't have the freedom, I won't have the physical ability to do them. And it's a really scary kind of idea to me. It's a really scary worry that I might regret my life and that maybe one
你拥有机会，并且你能够真正设计出一个灿烂无比的未来。非常感谢你收听这期节目。如果你喜欢它，请随时把它分享给你认为可能需要听到这个建议的朋友。请务必在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你正在收听的任何平台上给我们留下五星好评。我知道每个人都会这么说，但我真的会阅读每一条评论。我都会读，有时这甚至会给我带来负担，当我看到一星差评时，它真的会影响我的心情。但那里总是有那么多的爱和积极能量，让我感觉好受一些。所以，如果你已经这样做了，谢谢你。
day I won't, I would look back and realize that I didn't take the chances that I needed to. however this perspective I think allows for that allows for the fact that there is not a single thing in your life that is going to make you the happiest person alive or is going to bring you complete utter fulfillment and satisfaction it's a mindset it's a mindset of doing things every day that put you on a path for happiness and that prove to you day in and day out that you're investing in that future version of you and that you are dedicated to this current version of you and giving them the best kinds of experiences, giving them all the joy they could ask for, but also inserting that discipline to make sure that you keep doors open,
确保关注我们，这样你就能知道新节目何时发布。当然，如果你有节目建议、反馈、评论、想法、感受，无论是什么，请务必在 Instagram 上关注 That Psychology Podcast，你可以在那里给我们发私信。收听愉快。我们本周晚些时候再见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
you have opportunities and that you get to really design a brilliant, brilliant future. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you enjoyed it, please feel free to share it with a friend who you think may need to hear this advice. Make sure you leave us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening. I know everyone says this, but I truly do read them all. I read them all, probably at my, at my expense sometimes when I see like a one star review, it really gets in my head. But there's always so much love and positivity there that makes me feel better. So thank you if you have already done that.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理坚韧、健身和抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上的 TWO%，或在您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。
Make sure you are following us so you know when your episodes come out. And of course, if you have an episode suggestion, feedback, comments, thoughts, feelings, whatever it may be, make sure you are following us at that psychology podcast on Instagram and you can shoot us a DM over there. Happy listening. We will see you back again later this week. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）。在 80 年代。那是疯狂的一年。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will. come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为您带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话。有多少男人背负着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你需要这样做，
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill. on the 80s. It was a wild year.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，埃伦女士，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian.
保证人类制作本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我大受震撼。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人 本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。